Daniel: All right, next up is going to be
Keith Duggar, who has submitted a pre
recorded video.
The pre recorded video is called active
inference.
And the actor model So I will bring that
up right now.
Okay, here comes Keith's pre recorded
video on active inference and the Actor
model.
Keith: Active inference and the actor
Hello.
I'm Dr. Keith
Duggar, platform CTO at X Ray, an
extended reality AI
Company, and co host of Machine Learning
Street Talk podcast.
Now, as we all work to build an ecosystem
based on active inference, software will
obviously play a foundational role to
make the most of active inference.
We'll need to use software engineering
paradigms that align with the principles
of active inference, and I think there is
one tailor made for our needs.
It's called the actor model.
Active Inference and the Actor Model are
two deeply connected understandings of
the world.
They provide foundational frameworks for
dealing with the dynamics of complex
systems, with a focus on autonomous
agents that interact in an ecology of
nested systems.
I'd like to explore some of their key
connections, including the role of agents
concurrency, autonomy, uncertainty, and
behavior adaptation.
We will see that active inference and the
Active model are both paradigm shifts
away from a deterministic, centralized,
step by step thinking to a decentralized
network concurrent perspective of both
computation and cognition.
Just a little bit of history about the
Actor model.
Back in 1973, Karl Hewitt, Peter Bishop,
and Richard Steiger were all working at
the Massachusetts Institute of Technology
AI lab to Fundamentalize, a concept of
concurrent computation that included both
structure as well as adaptable algorithm
execution.
Conventional methods at the time lacked
robustness and secure mathematical
foundations.
Their collaborative effort ultimately led
to the creation of the Actor model.
At the time, it was viewed as
revolutionary due to its characteristics
of both increased error tolerance and
distributed computation abilities.
Throughout the 1980s and the 1990s, the
Actor model became a basis for numerous
research projects as well as practical
projects, gaining popularity for its
flexibility and intuitive approach to
concurrent computation.
It was primarily used in artificial
intelligence and multi agent systems.
Sound familiar?
New Actor based languages like Actor,
Saulson and Erlang contributed to the
refinement of the model, shaping it into
a more robust and flexible approach to
concurrent computing, and it remains
alive and well in computer science today.
.
More recently, the Actor model has gained
renewed interest, mainly due to the
growing need for distributed systems,
cloud computing and edge computing,
fueling the Internet of Things and Web 30.
.
These computer tasks are ideally suited
to take advantage of the ACA model's
architecture, which is designed exactly
for modeling concurrent handling of both
large volumes of data on the one hand,
and fine grained disparate autonomous
systems on the other hand.
This application of the Actor model has
had profound effects on major companies
that have utilized its principles to
handle big data problems such as Twitter,
Facebook, LinkedIn, so what does this
have to do with active inference?
I'm guessing you've already heard some of
the parallels in the intro.
But let's start by looking at a few core
principles of the actor model and how
they relate to the principles of active
inference.
Let's start with the concept of isolation.
.
Isolation means that an actor in the
actor model does not share its state with
any other actor.
It can only be affected by receiving a
message.
And it can only affect change in the
state of other actors by sending a finite
number of messages in response.
From a software engineering point of view,
, this isolation principle limits
potential side effects of an operation to
a single actor, thus improving the system'
's overall predictability reliability,
and most importantly, if embraced fully,
can actually simplify the design.
Looking at the diagram, we see an
ecosystem of actors sending messages to a
particular actor, which in turn sends
back messages to other actors.
Where is active inference?
Well, let's recast receiving and sending
messages to a perception action cycle and
denote external, internal, sensory and
active states.
And we now clearly have the necessary
foundation of active inference a Markov
blanket.
The actors of the actor model map
directly to the agents of active
inference.
In addition, the finiteness, the fact
that an actor can only send a finite
number of messages in response is also an
important shared property.
Because active inference models reality,
it necessarily respects the resource
constraints of real systems.
And this is nicely bathed into the
foundation of the active model.
Let's look at another core principle
asynchronous message passing.
Communication between actors is
asynchronous.
This means an actor doesn't wait for a
response after sending a message.
It continues working, it continues living,
, as it were.
This is critical as it decouples the
actors, leading to a system that can
continue functioning, living and making
progress even when parts of the system
are slow or even temporarily unavailable.
.
Professor Friston has said that the free
energy principle is the ultimate
existential question if things exist,
what must they do?
Well, the actor model claims they must
not wait on others.
Of course, an actor can choose to wait on
others, but it must not be forced to do
so in the model.
It must be free to choose.
This leads us to another critical
principle that both models share autonomy.
.
The free energy principle is a model of
physical reality and our reality is,
after all, concurrent.
All throughout infinite space, systems
are evolving simultaneously according to
their local dynamics.
And therefore this is reflected at the
heart of the free energy principle.
Of course, a model of computation need
not constrain itself to physics.
But Hewitt et al.
Were seeking to develop a model that did
model the reality of distributed
concurrent systems.
And luckily for us, the actor model
embraces both concurrency, seen from the
principle of isolation and actor autonomy,
, making it compatible with active
inference.
Next we come to nesting.
The actor model allows for an actor to
not only receive and send a finite number
of messages to perceive and act, it also
allows as an action the creation of a
finite number of new actors.
These actors can either be nested within
the parent, say, the parts of an animal
cell, or it can be released into the
environment as independent actors.
From then on this principle, the model
fits nicely with the beautiful concepts
of multiscale nesting and active
inference.
This allows for actors to contain
ecosystems of actors both all the way
down and all the way up.
Last, I want to cover two more actor
model design principles behavior change
and persistence.
Actors have the ability to change their
behavior in response to a message.
This adaptability allows for the
construction of complex stateful entities
that can evolve over time.
And indeed, it allows for entire
ecosystems to evolve new emergent
behaviors.
When used for software engineering, this
adds a powerful tool for managing complex
dynamic systems.
Active inference, of course, embraces
this to the extreme.
The very essence of thingness is the
ongoing attempt to predict and adapt to
an environment and thereby continue to
exist to maintain one's Markov blanket in
a broiling sea of activity.
Along with this also comes the concept of
persistence.
Persistence allows actors to sade their
state and to restore or modify it later a
feature that embodies the principle of
memory.
Memory is a prerequisite for learning and
adaptation.
An agent's ability to predict depends on
its ability to remember past experiences
and thus minimize the surprise associated
with unexpectedness.
The vital role of memory is also
emphasized when we assume that agents
have inductive priors, either from
experience or inheritance, contributing
to their world model.
This world model both guides their
current behavior and it is continuously
updated based on new experiences
contributing to their ongoing adaptation
and existence.
Okay, great.
You say there are clear and deep
connections between the actor model and
active inference.
But how does this help us in the active
inference community?
Well, firstly, in my opinion, it is a
software engineering paradigm we should
embrace.
And if we do, there are of course, actor
model libraries and frameworks that we
can use such as ACA, Orleans, thespian
Actix Protoactor and many more, which we
can immediately use when building active
inference software modules and
applications.
There are also libraries, languages and
even language features that align very
well with the actor model principles such
as Zero, MQ, tokyo and Rust, Erlang,
Async, Await and C.
Sharp, et cetera.
But more important than the tools
available to us today is the software
design mindset that will guide our
creation of the active inference software
of tomorrow.
The actor model provides a paradigm of
software design and engineering that is
the most perfect match that we have for
active inference.
This is evident not only from the
alignment of the core principles we
previously discussed, but also from the
insights that active inference in the
actor model bring to each other.
For example, consider what is now called
Hewitt's Law.
Informally stated as everything is
everywhere, this law signifies the idea
that in a truly asynchronous distributed
system, it can take an arbitrary amount
of time for a message to go from one
place to another, and any actor must be
prepared for that event.
There is simply no such thing as
instantaneous in such a system, and no
component can make an assumption about
the timing of another component's actions.
.
In fact, one must act as if a message may
never arrive.
This has important implications.
It suggests that it is impossible to
accurately and consistently determine the
state of the entire system at any given
time, because the information just may
not have even propagated across the
system.
And also attempts to implement global
synchronization will inevitably introduce
bottlenecks and reduce efficiency.
Hewitt's Law emphasizes the need for
systems to be designed in a way that they
can effectively handle these unavoidable
delays and uncertainties, highlighting
the importance of robust nonblocking
communication mechanisms and local
decision making abilities.
In short, Hector model systems are by
nature nondeterministic.
Does this sound familiar?
What other paradigm highlights operation
under uncertainty and the autonomy to
continue despite the environment?
Active Inference and the free energy
principle?
Active inference reflects the reality of
an unpredictable world in which our
software systems operate.
Different outcomes may result from the
same initial conditions due to the
occurrence of events in a random,
unpredictable order.
This is the concept of surprise that we
all know well, where an agent updates its
beliefs about the world when the sensory
input it receives does not match its
predictions.
Both the actor model and active inference
acknowledge that the world is
unpredictable.
Even more than acknowledge it, the models
accept this uncertainty as a given and
not something to be managed away.
Indeed, as we know in the free energy
principle, the uncertainty that we
maintain in our models is what gives us
the flexibility to adapt.
Perhaps this is just my personal flight
of fancy, but I imagine a future where
software modules guided by active
inference do away with hard coded error
handling and swap in probabilistic
learning algorithms that optimize
themselves as the error landscape evolves.
.
Modules that are robust and self healing
distributed systems with no single points
of failure that focus on predictive
disaster avoidance rather than reactive
disaster recovery.
Looking towards the future, we as a
community have the potential to push the
boundary of both active imprints theory
and practical implementations of the
actor model.
By leveraging the strengths of these two
paradigms together, we can create
software systems that are robust,
adaptive and more aligned to the physical
world in which they actually operate.
Imagine a future where software
components using active inference in the
actor model can anticipate potential
issues, learn from past mistakes, and
adapt in real time to environmental
changes.
With this approach, we can build systems
that are fundamentally more resilient and
more efficient.
In my opinion, this can bring a step
change in software reliability and
performance and scalability, and heralds
a new era of computing, weaving
principles of biology and cognition into
the fabric of our software systems,
bringing them closer to life in the
process.
In conclusion, the coupling of active
inference to the actor model provides a
powerful new lens through which we can
look at software design and engineering.
Whether we leverage existing languages
and libraries aligned with active
inference or invent new ones, we are
standing on the brink of an exciting
frontier.
So let's seize the day, have a look at
the actor model and its relationship to
active inference, and let's shape the
future of intelligent distributed
computing.
Thank you for listening.
Daniel: Awesome.
Great talk by Keith.
Thank you, Keith, for sending that in.
There were some comments in the chat.
So, Keith, potentially if you want to
join for A-Q-A some future time, but
really cool presentation.